what'd you think of uh Lebron and uh
Dylan Brooks
LeBron went beast mode bro Dylan Brooks
sucks dude I remember watching the
playoffs last year and tweeting is it
just me or does Dylan Brooks suck and
then he just kept talking and then I've
been talking to people like from Memphis
like postings from Memphis and I was
like am I wrong or is he not even a good
Defender and Postman was like no he's
not a good Defender none of us in
Memphis like him he just keeps running
his [__] mouth he's gonna cost him
this series yeah I mean LeBron LeBron
stepped up bro I mean even like the was
it game tying layout yeah the game tying
and Regulation and the game ceiling in
overtime on Dylan Brooks and then Dylan
was like one was on Brooks I think one
was on another guy yeah overtime one was
on Brooks that like sealed the game I
think they were up two or five and then
he got a three-point play yeah like 20
seconds um and then Dylan Brooks a few
months earlier was like if I go to
LeBron it's foursome left and I really
think LeBron was like we're up a few
anyway I'm gonna go left on this
[__] yeah Jessica's [__] you I
mean it's great to see him still be in
it yeah it is bro it is I didn't agree
with that call though
the flagrant too fell oh have you seen
the angle where it's very clear he
punches him in the dick there's one
angle that is I was like give him a
playground one
yeah why like flagrant two used to be
like hey you went for their head you
stomped on a guy some real [__] that is
just like that's just play time for
y'all white [__] hitting
somebody in the nuts I don't know you
punch him in the nuts in the middle of
the [__] the plants like that's a
flag but also you gotta understand when
you started this beef
so like you put all they're like what do
you say like the pregame Shenanigans are
probably or the pregame context like
added to the flavor two call it's like
you created the pregame context sure yes
this is on you if you want to build up
all this smoke then you have to know
what's going on you're hoping that this
smoke affects LeBron psyche and he plays
worse yeah what it did is maybe affected
the way that the refs perceived your
defense right and now you're out of here
oh you're antagonistic oh you're PL
you're talking aggressive now you're
playing aggressive and then any
aggressive play you have is now being
looked at through that light that's true
it's on you you because if LeBron did
play worse because you were in his head
you'd be you would take full
accountability for that right yeah you
bet I got in his head yeah I told you
and now he never goes left well you got
in the refs head yep dumb Bozo [__] yeah
listen not a flavor too though okay okay
but we're doing the old dude thing we're
doing the old head thing where it's like
uh everything's a foul these games are
tougher in my day yeah yeah I see what
you're saying also
um probably was good for the Grizzlies
that he got thrown out the game you know
what I mean he doesn't do anything
look at this this is the game time
bucket he just gets passed up left help
fouls him otherwise easy layup
yeah you deserve that he doesn't want to
go left he doesn't want to go left I
wonder if LeBron's like I'm I could go
anyway on you yeah I really think he's
because again I think they're up five at
this point or three I think this is the
game ceiling one I think this is
overtime yeah no T1 they're up I think
five at this point and then he gets the
M1 or maybe three and then he gets the
animal but either way it's it's over and
like if since we're already up I'll just
seal it on him let's go left I got some
time Batman is 38 years old that's not
insane that man has been playing
basketball bro Shifty said this he said
he got drafted before he was born that's
so cool
professional basketball I mean granted
he's spending millions of dollars on his
body whatever you can say whatever the
[__] you want I don't give a [__] that
man is playing basketball at the highest
level
every other night yes that is one day of
rest
every other night basketball at the
highest [__] 45 this game yeah Dylan
Brooks I think was six or seven years
old when LeBron got drafted 38 years old
38 year old knees
every other night playoff intensity 45
minutes carrying the team team on his
back
bro I'm not saying we got to go LeBron
is better than Jordan whatever who gives
a [__] yeah but just to say that we're
not witnessing greatness yeah oh I don't
know you just you a hater bro yeah I'm
sorry you hate says that at this point
bro I'm hoping the Lakers they won't now
I was hoping they would lose just
because then maybe the they would want
to trade for Kyrie and as a Mavs fan I
don't want Kyrie yeah so I'm actively
rooting against him but he's playing I
mean it's so fun to watch yeah it's so
fun to watch yeah it's insane so now
what is the series with Memphis Three
one three one and the Warriors they
don't look as good as the Kings but
Darren Fox broke his finger on a
shooting huge and he's been playing
[__] insanely switch finger shooting
I think he's is he lefty or righty
whatever his Lefty but you know which
finger index
now I will say he's not much of like a
three-point uh threat but but he is that
mid-range threat like elbow extended
yeah he is is playing fantastic he's
been playing
they could have very easily won the last
game in Golden State they would have
been up 3-1 since they lost his 2-2 and
he's hurt so I think it's gonna be
Lakers Warriors all right guys we gotta
take a break from this exclusive patreon
clip because I gotta tell y'all about
the hardest dicks in the game in this
Bluetooth delivering them that's right
same active ingredients as inside Cialis
or Viagra this is the true this is the
one that we rock with and the one that's
gonna have your girl satisfied and
sticky maybe go right to sleep God Bless
The Chew and you're gonna get it for
free first month for free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars shipping when you
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
flagrant
your girl is welcome and you are welcome
too now let's get back to this exclusive
patreon clip you could join the [__]
Army get a new episode from us every
single week
at patreon.com
is fantastic let's say the Lakers make
it out and let's say the Knicks let's
say the Heat beat the Bucks which is
very possible I think the heater up 3-1
now right
so let's say the Heat beat the bucks
then you have Nick's heat you have
Lakers warriors
uh and then ideally it would be Knicks
versus
Celtics yeah because I think the Celtics
beat the 76ers yeah not even a question
and then
it would be Nick Celtics and then it
would be Lakers
uh
uh uh nuggets probably or Sons Sons
so Lakers Sons KD against LeBron and
then Knicks Celtics who does Boston have
to get past uh the 76ers and then
whoever makes it to the uh like
Conference Finals yeah
Boston swept the net should probably be
the next yeah yeah Boston plays tonight
no
crazy but that I mean that would be a
very fun yeah it'd be very fun
Conference Finals and then finals yeah
yeah I think Nick's got it this year bro
[Music]
before we do too much of this digital
talk why don't you just get the patreon
questions ready now let's get back to
delusion what happened to you bro no no
I'm all about Nick's illusion no but you
used to be a fan oh stop this don't do
this nah like you really like something
happened you're not as into it I am not
as into basketball as I happen to go to
a game this season I did
how many
with season tickets with season tickets
game right I went to one Knicks game
two next games yeah yeah two next games
all right I saw you at the I'll be there
for you in Brooklyn if the Knicks don't
close it out I'll be there Friday don't
worry
I went to one next game the only thing
went to one more than me yep I don't
even like this yeah so step it up I know
I need to step it up I need to step it
up I need to go harder you're right
you're right when's the next game
tomorrow right tonight
oh it's tonight yeah [__] I'm my boss
but not here oh [__] I think they're in
Cleveland I think they come back Friday
that is funny you're saying he's not a
Knicks fan you don't even know what's
going on at all come on it's too many
black people
yeah we need more Indians yeah I know
yeah yeah we have more Indians for the
next I wouldn't know
okay let's get some potatoes
I think I mean Indian NBA players no
there was that guy said no I'm saying
but they sent him overseas it was more
of like a what about that big mother
Bulbasaur or whatever the [__] his name
was
I think he plays uh overseas I think
this is yeah we got a symbolar satnam
Singh played for the Mavs back in the
day principal saying it's a g league and
then they got Kyrie on here for some
reason I mean he's Israelis I guess it's
close yeah that's true yeah
would you all be friends if you met in
high school are we all the same age
I think so
yeah I think in this hypothetical yeah
okay yeah I think so yeah we're not
going back into High School closer it's
okay yeah I'm just you know that's gonna
be kind of younger yeah so no we
wouldn't be friends with Mark
you'd be the manager of the basketball
team or whatever you know baseball team
yeah yeah we wouldn't play that gay
sport so uh more soccer you guys are
playing the soccer team with me if you
wanted to yeah yeah we really wouldn't
have been yeah
bro
I'm not hanging out with him okay
yeah yeah at the white boy school
yes you didn't want to school
um yeah no we don't hang out in high
school I'm trying to think like I think
it would be I don't know how much we'd
hang out but I think we'd all be cool
yeah that's the thing I don't know were
you guys losers in high school at all no
maybe I mean maybe who knows
maybe
I was well liked but I didn't hang out
well what was your superlative
yeah
I could have been I can't tell you my my
Bianca
it might be I don't know what popular
that should have been as a fat kid I
know that you were going to studying
though you were going to school so you
might have tutored him at some point
yeah I was decent at school and even
though I was good at school oh school's
easy bro yeah school was easy